storks is directed by nicholas stoller
the man behind forgetting sarah marshall
and the neighbors films so this is
definitely a bit of a departure for him
as this is a family movie and in this
movie storks no longer delivered babies
they deliver packages and junior voiced
by Andy Samberg is looking at a major
promotion if he can just do one thing
fire a very annoying girl who was left
there who has no idea who her family is
and when a young boy out there finds an
old ad for what storks used to do he
writes them hoping for a baby and this
baby is accidentally created than thus
this girl and the stork have to team up
to deliver this baby to this family and
it gets difficult that's the best way to
put it I guess I really didn't have much
anticipation for this movie in fact I
hadn't even seen any of the trailers I
saw I think the teaser where was just a
stork standing in front of a conveyor
belt that's all I remember so I really
didn't know anything about this film
going in so I was pleasantly surprised
when the movie turned out to be actually
pretty good this is a very fast paced
film in a similar vein to the lego movie
was it's extremely quick there's a lot
of quips a lot of jokes and they fly
very fast and that kept things moving at
a very brisk pace I found myself having
a lot of fun with storks and I really
had storks this movie was actually good
night okay the best part of this movie
for me was a relationship between the
stork and the girl these two characters
fleshed out each other very well and I
liked watching them grow it kind of
snuck up on me it surprised me in that I
was genuinely interested and invested in
their friendship and that was something
that definitely took me off-guard
because I went into this movie I really
had no anticipation for it and I think
that would be my best recommendation to
anyone else who goes to see this film
the animation and the character design
is also very stellar I really liked
Kelsey Grammer as the boss he was really
funny and I also loved the little kid
who desperately wants to have a brother
who writes a letter to these storks
requesting the baby has ninja skills I
like this little kid a lot he kind of
reminded me of me when I was a kid and
screw it me as an adult to caerse I
would love to have a ninjas skill friend
and wear in other animated films the
character like that that gets the plot
moving the kid sends the letter that
gets the baby
made then creates the problem and now we
have a movie that character is generally
like the guy who just opposite just it
happened and now we have a movie like
they just kind of throw that character
to the side but this character was
actually given a compelling story on his
own and it wasn't just like to cut back
every once in a while to make us care
about this kid again
his parents are becoming a little
absent-minded they're getting really
into their jobs and they're forgetting
to entertain their kid and that whole
story in which these parents try to
reconnect with their son I thought was
really touching as for issues with the
movie it's not like you watch this movie
and just go that's bad like that's the
part that I don't like I suppose the
biggest issue I have with it is that
sometimes it does favor humor over
characterization and it does sometimes
feel like a series of sketches we're
seen sometimes don't feel like they have
a meaning beyond just let's have a funny
part here yay
for young kids that's not going to be an
issue at all though kids are going to
really have fun with this movie and I
think adults are surprisingly going to
like it too
this movie did surprise me the
characters are mostly well fleshed out
although there are some side characters
that are just there specifically to make
jokes which again really isn't an issue
I'm going to give stork's a b/c I didn't
see the theatrical trailer because I've
stayed away from trailers for the most
part if I can so if there are a lot of
jokes in that trailer that are ruined
for you I'm sorry hopefully that doesn't
happen to you because I didn't know
anything going in and that was a good
thing and I just have to mention this I
got probably the best letter I've ever
received from a fan in my entire life in
my p.o box and I just have to read it
dear Chris Stockman there is one thing I
want to tell you you're the best
youtuber in the world I absolutely love
your videos when I'm sad you're always
here to cheer me up
you're my hero and I love you I live in
Ireland and I'm 10 years old if I meet
you one day I would go crazy and be so
happy I hope we can be friends from
Bayley your number one fan
Bailey your letter made me cry man that
was awesome thank you very much for that
and thank you for watching my videos
Bailey it really means a lot to me thank
you and I just want to also say thank
you so much to the people who have sent
me some things in my p.o box I'm sorry
that I haven't done any unboxings or
anything I've gotten a lot of really
cool things some movies TV shows some
stuff from
collodion even which was really awesome
and I just want to say thank you to all
you guys it's just that I don't really
do unboxing videos I'll try to find a
way to incorporate those into my videos
in the future but Bailey you're the man
also I want to let you know that my
promotion with crunchyroll is still
going if you go to crunchyroll.com slash
chris stuckman you can get a free 30-day
trial of the best anime streaming
service available to the public these
guys are incredible they've been
supporting anime for quite some time and
if you go to crunchyroll.com slash Chris
Stockman they have so many great shows
streaming in HD and sometimes you can
get them straight from Japan just a few
hours after the air in Japan which is
incredible as a big anime fan this means
a lot to me and I love the fact that
they're sponsoring my video so thank you
very much to crunchyroll go to
crunchyroll.com slash chris stuckman for
a free 30-day trial thank you to you
guys for watching as always you're the
best and if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]